nous sommes ici juste pour vous parler de ce
Robocop qui est une initiative visant à créer des
équipes de robots autonomes capables de jouer à
un jeu dans un environnement contradictoire et
ce jeu est le football robot et le but
de cette recherche sur le football robot est d'essayer
de développer des techniques pour  des robots de manière
autonome pour coordonner pour négocier
pour apprendre à élaborer des stratégies dans des environnements
surgissent complexes comme des
environnements contradictoires un jour en 2050 nous espérons
que les équipes de robots de football seront en mesure
de vaincre ou de jouer avec les champions les
champions humains de la Coupe du monde
Robocop arrive à Montréal
en 2018 et vous aurez la chance de voir la
vie de Robocop